now one of the side stories at CPAC is
that MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell had a
complete and total meltdown in the
exhibit hall uh Robert Costa is a
reporter for CBS News and there's video
of pillow
flipping out and calling Robert Costa a
traitor there are times when if a
business leader behaved this way their
business would be shut down within a
month because everybody would say I'm
not going to buy from this guy but look
at the behavior of pillow check this out
okay so we actually have a better angle
and audio so this is from Robert Costa
actually filming it himself and pillows
completely irrational he seems totally
out of his mind and Trump actually
during his speech said Mike pillow's
here he's so great and the crowd gave
him a standing ovation this is how the
guy was behaving in the hallway
[Applause]
is a traitor to the United by the way
Costco I love them
no you're a Trader this is old news your
regurgitative you care about where you
protect the company called dominion and
you attack a company call my pillow
you're a traitor to our country and
you're a disgusting thing
[Music]
you're disgusting
what's funny is Costa's really a pretty
uncontroversial reporter he's just he's
just a reporter
one doesn't talk at all
he's asking
if you're at the White House a year ago
you're disgusting by the way the picture
at the White House a year ago where
pillow came out and the zoom in showed
that it said like State of Emergency on
his piece of paper martial law something
like that that's that we still haven't
really gotten answers to that and I
asked pillow about it during our
interview and he was he was pretty
evasive it's hard to find a more
deranged guy more in over his head than
Mike pillow and Trump actually praised
him and uh here's just one more clip
this is Phoenix kid reporter asking
pillow for an example of the election
fraud and um pillow didn't like it and
walked away
here we go
so what did you think of President
Trump's speech one of his best ones ever
and why do you think that is well
because he brought up all the election
crimes
the 2020 election crimes all this stuff
is happening we got to keep getting the
word out and he told the media how
rotten they are that they never reported
anything that's that's going to help
save our country what are election
crimes
luxury crimes yes are you serious
are you serious really no I'm saying for
people who haven't really heard no they
all know tell them to go to
frankspeeds.com Lindale TV you can see
all the crime right there
and then he walks away uh Phoenix kid
reporter instantly triggering uh Mike
pillow there so it's out of control
after the break we'll talk about the
event next door aft pack the openly
white nationalist competitor to CPAC